we are here with my dear friend
naturalist and lifestyle expert danny
siehoe and boy does he have the goods
danny ceo you have changed my life
um yet again what are we doing this time
okay so if you can't save that sweater
because it's far too gone or maybe it's
like a cashmere sweater or a very nice
soft cozy expensive sweater you don't
want to donate it quite yet we're gonna
reupholster a chair and make cozy
sweater chairs oh my god that's so cute
like how cute is that so like you've
never seen that before like imagine just
sitting on cashmere this is the world's
easiest craft project so i'm inspired by
like let's imagine it's a mix of
macgyver and drew barrymore okay
i love the
combination resourceful so you pop off
um the seat cushion from a chair so this
is pretty easy to do there's little
screws on the bottom that you just pop
out and you have this like empty cushion
right here you rip off the old fabric
and what we're gonna do is that you cut
the sweater you want a big flat piece so
you see what we've done here just a nice
big flat piece
and then we're going to take our seat
cushion
on the cushion side all the way up
you wrap it on top and this is where you
want to kind of like you know make sure
you get the pattern right if it's like
an argyle or a zigzag or stripes that's
where you have to just really kind of
look at it but we love a solid because
you can't screw up
so they say and then we're going to flip
it over just like this and what's kind
of nice is it already has like existing
uh staples in place you can use it as a
guide
and what i just do drew
[Laughter]
and then you just staple
go like this and then i do one in the
middle here i go one in the middle here
and then you go all the way around and
then you're kind of just stretching it
to make sure it's tight and taut the
same way that a professional would do
this i'm gonna go all the way here
we're gonna do this and you just go
around and around danny turn around do
you like wrap a gift is it like well i
don't use a staple gun really
like
our mutual friend martha stewart came on
the show and she taught me how to wrap a
gift and it it changed my life did you
just say mutual friend martha stewart
don't you know her i don't know her
really
well in my life now i'm like what what
what did she say
it's so funny i feel like in my fantasy
we're all hanging out i was like i'm
telling you i i have this fantasy we
need to make it happen i am going to
have an ambulance nearby because i will
be having an aneurysm during the whole
time
okay so you staple all the way around
you trim the excess and then look at
this guys it's a supercharger i don't
know what that is
that's really good so you can see guys
we have a blue one here or you have this
beautiful like
more of a
ski lodge the pink one i love the pink
look how cute that is and you could
literally do
you could literally do
i i just need we just need a third seat
for uh our mutual friend martha stewart
come join danny and i and danny wanted
to help everyone get started on their
cleaning journey so he is kindly giving
everyone in our audience a 100
scouts honor gift card
it's the world's best cleaning product i
and they are according to danny
some of the world's best cleaning
products and if there's anyone i trust
on this planet to take care of our
planet it is you danny
and think about all the things you are
doing i mean you are really at the
forefront of a movement that not only we
all need to get on but like you were way
ahead of the curve and you are such a
success story and we're all literally
going to live better lives for it oh
thank you drew danny congratulations
again
[Applause]
thank you everybody go to the
[Applause]
of drewberrymartial.com chairs
[Applause]
[Music]